we all know this field is in constant
change and it's defined and pulled and
twisted and redefined and our next
speaker dr emmanuel ruiz will discuss
how omics data is changing our molecular
applications dr ruiz was awarded a phd
in molecular and cellular biology
throughout the years she was confronted
with the need for computational biology
tools in order to answer biological
questions and she had to acquire an
expertise on bioinformatics
and biostatistics dr ruiz can't wait to
hear what you got for us you're on stage
can you turn your video on by the way
i cannot hear you or see you dr ruiz
here we are
hello sorry there you are
let me try again
all right yeah
i can hear you fine if you want to go to
slideshow mode that would be great there
we go
thank you good luck
thank you my name is emmanuel ruiz and i
am a senior postdoc bioinformatician in
the veterinary school of louisiana state
university it's an honor today to
present my work experience from the
bench to the computer and how
bioinformatics with all mixed data have
drastically changed my career path
so i was born raised and got my
education in neon friends i completed my
phd in the cancer research center of
young and the main purpose of the
research project was to decipher the
interaction and the collaboration
between the epithelial mosaicable
transition regulators with oncogenic
stresses that lead to mammary
transformation
this research project was initially a
basic project with bench or in vitro
data that would have been validated in
animals models and with luck finally in
human subject however as you will see in
the next slide very soon the bench
results obtained could not anymore be
interpreted or analyzed further with
basic molecular
or cellular
biologicals the goal was to
understand if and how
the emt transcription factors were
collaborating with oncogenic stresses to
transform non-cancer mammary cells and
compare this new oncogenic abilities or
properties between these emttfs
the methodology is chosen has been a
screaming
where the tense comes transcription
factors will be compared in four
unconcerning stresses
condition
the deletion of p10 of p53 the
overexpression of egfr or the
mutation mutational activation of
beta-cartene
that are all
unconcerning stress found in breast
cancer
so briefly the virus contained the 10
transcription factor sequences were
produced and infected in mammary cells
that were already altered by a
non-cautioning stress the origin
original mammary cell line did not
possess oncogenic properties or
transformed abilities and adding this
unconcerning stress was not enough to
make them conscious
the infected mammary says we are grown
in the soft tiger plate that meaning the
transformation process
and only cancer cells or transformed
cells can grow in soft tiger
after several days clones were collected
and amplified
rna were extracted and pcr were run in
order to identify which emt tfs have
been overexpressed in the crohn's
in parallel
a functional test as softagar
preferation and immigration assay was
performed to compare their unconscioning
properties
initially we anticipated to analyze
clones that have maybe one or two
transcription factors overexpressed
however because of a screening we obtain
clones that contain from one to six and
seven transcription factors per clone
and furthermore the functional tests
were showing that these clothes
presented a high diversity of
transformer proliferative and migration
properties
so a bigger picture of what was
originally so was building up and all
this information have to be computed and
analyzed but how and here's
bioinformatics and biostatistics were
the keys
and so we collaborate with a
biopharmatician and we gave her this
simple excel spice that contains the
combination of the emt ts in the column
for each clone that are in the row and
for the different condition transformers
and non-transformers and for the
specific unquestioning stresses
we ask a specific question as we all the
time have to do when we talk with
biopharmaceutician one question at the
time which ents combination or signature
were the most associated with a specific
on cushioning stress she thought that a
base a tree based model classification
could help to answer a question but at
this time so
like 10 years ago more or less
the tree that we obtained didn't make
sense for me and i was quite confused on
how to use them in order to answer this
biolus biological question
so i decided to go deeper in the
classification
process and understand the different
steps or how they were build and
how we had these complete trees
at this time i only have excels to help
me but i succeed to find a meaning and
also
i succeed to create a new visualization
that computes the number of the emttfs
that we see on the circle
the colored circles
the emttf signature
and also that predicts the importance of
the rank inside this signature
and so finally
also this visualization could predict
the ability to drive mammary
transformation represented by the width
of the cycle the triangle shows that
their transformer abilities depending
only on their rank if there were not
other
parameters out
altering this transformativity
and
we could see that we can see on the
visualization that the first
emt tfs that have the strongest um
ability to predict that to
predict the transformation
properties of the cells uh will be on
the
on the top of the triangle with the
first on the signature and the one that
has the less abilities will be on the
bottom however when we put them together
we saw that we had a different signature
according the transformers um
according the unconscioning stress and
also um inside the ginseng this emt
signature
um the transcription factors have an
importance that were different and so we
could
identify specific emt mixture according
the oncogenic stress
this analysis was the beginning of
understanding the bigger picture of the
interaction and collaborations between
emtts in the context of a specific
encouraging stress during mammary
transformation in parallel to this
project
the years of my phd were also associated
with the emergence of transcriptomic
and genomic data online platforms it was
a decade now that the first human genome
had been sequenced different institutes
like the national cancer institute
nci and the national human genome
research were joining force to propose
genomic
epigenomic transcriptomic protein and
also clinical data on cancer tissue with
the tcga
the cancer genome atlas also on cell
line with the cancer cell and
encyclopedia and all that for the
international research community with a
free access
the possibilities to validate and
understand the bigger picture of what
uh we obtain from our bench results we
are now within everyone rich even the
ones that didn't have any bioinformatics
expertise
my bioinformatic curiosity
already
initiated by my own project were fit by
my
boss that wanted to use this new tool
and i took the challenge to learn how to
use them what i didn't know at this time
is i will fell in love and be addicted
to bioinformatics
the bench was has maybe most a lot of
you know
where we can spend hundreds of hours
trying to accumulate results and dispose
them of a kind of puzzled pieces were
not any more very exciting for me
and i largely prefer to spend the same
amount of time resolving bioinformatics
puzzles so
as i say previously i was using excess
in at the first
tools and excelsion very quickly its
limits and i had to learn from scratch
real bioinformatics and biostatistics
software like r so i didn't take um
university classes but already at this
time and more today
there are excellent tutorials online
that are free or not much expensive
and uh forums where i cool and i
continue to ask the dumbest question
without any shame and
people are
very patient to answer them and so all
this the fruit of this effort uh lead me
to have different collaborations during
my phd and one of them uh lead to a
publication in nature medicine so i was
quite um
encouraged by that so after that i left
france
and worked as a postdoc fellow um in the
university school of medicine with dr
kendall has api dr candide is an
endocrine surgeon specialized in tariff
cancer and so my research work was
strongly driven by a clinical
perspective it was actually a very good
training to never forget that my
research project even is driven by a
strong
curiosity have all the time
to have in mind and
that in the end
the research project have to help
patients and so today i would like to
share with you
two projects that show how much
bioinformatics is a tremendous help to
answer clinical and translational
questions and problematics so the first
project is relative to cancer and aging
so cancers are aging disease
and so more we get older and mother
cancer incidence increases however the
link between aging and aggressive cancer
is not clearly defined except in one
type of cancer thyroid cancer
thyroid cancer is the only cancer where
clinicians have established standardized
prognosis marker using age as a markup
component because older patients older
than 55
have a higher risk of cancer specific
tests
however it is not the case for every
older thyroid cancer patient and it is
crucial to identify which one which all
patients will present a high risk of
poor outcome and aggressive tumors
the new identified by prognosis marker
will assist clinician to establish
personalized and more accurate
therapeutic strategies
first for the height with patient with
more aggressive therapies
and also for the lowest patient with
less aggressive therapies or active
surveillance where no surgery is
proposed but a regular control follow-up
will check the evolution of these
low-risk tumors
the active surveillance is a future of
thyroid cancer has a majority of this
cancer are low risk but consequencing of
surgery and treatment are high
so in order to
discover this biomarker we use the tcga
thyroid cancer and the gtech started
normal tissue datasets
and different expression gene expression
analysis were performed with a dec 2 r
package so using the r software in order
to select which genes were the most
significantly differentiated x-rays in
this support aggressive aging cancer
population
so we perform different comparison
analysis
between aging cancer with aging normal
tissue young cancer neuron normal tissue
aging normal and young normal tissue in
order to select to select specifically
the aging cancer gene
and we find 198
from this first selection
other deiser analysis were performed
comparing the clinical uh and survival
parameters and we filter the 190 egg
genes
on 72 cancer aging specific but also
aggressive genes
as we focus on an aggressive phenotype
associated with the aging process
the same analysis but adjusting the
parameters with age were next performed
and the
72 were filtered as 48 cancer agent
specific
and aging dependent aggressive chains
finally has a
internal validation the same analysis
were performed only on the aging core to
be sure that this
the gene selected continue to be
associated with an aggressive phenotype
in this aging world and we finally
define 23 genes that are cancer agent
specific and aging dependent aggressive
for computing the expression value and
the beta coefficient of regression
analysis of these 23 uh genes we are
calculating
this core validated the strong
association of the event there was a 23
gene signature with aggressive phenotype
and also with the poor outcome
the score powers to predict the
aggressiveness
to predict aggressive phenotype of this
poor outcome were estimated with a
receiver operative curve analysis the
interpretation of the curve is the
following the area under curve auc the
closest is this to one and the strongest
the power the predictive power to
classify
is is and so as you can see on this
curve the 23dg panel presented a very
strong auc superior to 0.7 from what of
the clinical parameter analyzed hence
this 23dg signature predict aggressive
tumor
phenotype in the all-tied cancer patient
we went further and we compared this
2013 panel with abilities to disk um to
uh identify the
height risk patient with already
standardized clinical markers that are
used in clinique today
and so um
we observed that actually the 23 dhg
panel presented a significant and
strongly strongest prediction that the
age system the hgcc system when we were
predicting the overall survival but also
again the ata risk classification uh
that predict for recurrence with a
disease-free survival and
progression-free interval handsome
this 23 gene signature is a potential
prognosis marker for aging thyroid
carcinoma and also can be used
complementary to the standardized
prognosis markers
finally
for a principal component analysis and
your sql clustering two subcluster of
this aging cancer population could be
identified the less aggressive engine
cluster and the more aggressive aging
cluster
so we have discovered a 23dg aging panel
that predicts which all patients will
present a poor outcome and aggressive
phenotype
validation in other databases and also
in human subject
will be needed of course and of course
to conclude this panel may lead to a
more accurate personalized therapy and a
better understanding of how aging
aggravate cancer progression
so the second project that i want to
share with you is related to the cancer
process the resistance process after
bureau of inhibitor treatment in
melanoma patients
for more than 60 percent of melanoma and
also in thyroid cancer present a
mutation of the kinase
biruff the main mutation found is the
v600e
with the volume the 600 amino acid of
duraprotein is replaced by glutamine
acid
the mutation leads to a change in the
protein conformation making the kinase
pocket being over-activated
the over-activated kinase leads to an
increase of proliferation and survival
of the mutated cells
and so create and drive a
tumor agencies
the over-activated kinase
so drugs were designed to be competitive
substrate especially of
on this mutated kinase and so under
buravi android 60e inhibitor treatment
melanoma shrinks and patients will be in
remission
however or unfortunately most of the
patients will relapse in the next 18
months after the end of the treatment
because cancer cells will have induced
resistant mechanism against the specific
drugs
so it is crucial to
discover new biomarkers as a gene panel
in order to identify which patients have
a high risk of recurrence the new
biomarker will have clinician to adjust
the therapeutic strategy by proposing
a combination of treatment
with the biref inhibitors and drugs
preventing the resistance process or by
choosing another frontline therapy as a
immunotherapy
so the project began at the bench where
our team was looking to understand the
resistance mechanism after a birth
inhibitor treatment
because these mechanisms are quite still
unclear so we perform an in vitro
melanoma model of resistance
we use sorry an in vitro melanoma model
of resistance and we performed a
proteomic assay among more than the
active different proteins 18
were differentially expressed in the
resistance samples compared to the
sensitive one
next we were interesting to see how
these proteins were behaving in human
melanoma resistant models
in our knowledge they were not protein
data available online to answer our
question so we decided to look for
transcriptomic data in the gic dataset
rep repository we found five data sets
of human melanoma samples that were
treated with brave inhibitors and
present resistance we focus on the first
the gac 1988
has a discovery panel and we validate
our results in the other data set
so first we checked
the differential expression of the 18
genes according to the resistance stage
and we saw that most were deregulated
but few presented a significant
difference
however when we run a principal
component analysis in order to estimate
the importance of the contribution of
the actin gene to explain the
heterogeneity observed across the
samples we saw that the actin gene could
significantly
differentiate the samples according to
the resistance stage
with the pink samples
uh represent the sensitive one and are
in the left of the plot whereas the blue
samples that represent the resistance
samples at are the right of the plot
furthermore uh the genes
presented a variety of correlation
as we see on the right plot but also a
variety of contribution to the pcr with
the red uh um one cons having a high
contribution
whereas the blue one having a
lower contribution
and so as we observed that all the
acting didn't have the same contribution
to the resistance discrimination we
decide to filter them and select a
signature that presents the strongest
predictive power to stratify the sample
the sample sorry according to the
resistance stage
to this aim we use the supervised
machine learning linear discriminant
analysis methodology
for every combination possible between
the acting genes so
262 hundred thousand 153 possibilities
all these combinations were tested and
the criteria of selection used was a
rogue analysis with the estimation of
the area under curve of the auc
so the combination presenting the
highest auc
have been chosen it was a combination of
18 gene
and this exchanging signature present a
discriminator
discriminatory strength of 0.98
as the auc in the discovery data set
linear regressions and other statistical
tests
shown strong significant p values and
other data sets used
has validation tests presented similar
results
finally a merge of the five data set in
order to obtain a data set that have a
height number of samples were built with
the computation of the corresponding
z-score for the individual previous data
sets and this merge
shown also a very strong discriminative
power
to of this certain gene signature to
predict resistance in human melanoma
samples the rockers illustrate the table
the previous table with the six analysis
the five data set and the measures of
the the data set and we observe that all
of them have auc superior to 0.7 the 18
genes core has previously for the actins
gene were also differentially expressed
according the resistance stage in all
the data sets
and through a pca we could see that the
acting gene explains the difference
observed across the samples because of
the resistance process
so we have
discovered a certain gig resistant
panels that predict which melanoma
patient will relapse after a birav v600e
inhibitor treatment has previously said
validation in other datasets and human
subjects are needed
to conclude for this project this
potential therapeutic
marker might help clinician to
accurately establish a personalized
therapy this panel analysis will improve
the understanding of drug resistance
mechanism
and so today
i work full time as a bioinformatician
finnish
bench works
and i work at the vet school of lsu at
baton rouge with dr kusulas being part
of the
uh i am part of the lbrn has assistant
director of the bioinformatic
biostatistic and computational
biological
and i will it will be my pla and i will
be
the lesion between the lbr and community
and the pan biotech it will be my
pleasure my pleasure to collaborate and
help and mentor you for your
biopharmaceutic or biostatistical needs
thank you
you're you're unmuted there grant
there we go thank you emmanuel we
appreciate all of that information um
we have learned so much from everybody
today and you're working in a changing
world changing data structures and it
must be a huge challenge thank you for
delving deeper and giving us more
understanding in what you're doing i'm
going to ask you a few questions that
we've got in
and
i'm going to get you a start here what
are the challenges in bioinformatics in
relevance to personalized medicine
on my experience what i observed is um
there is the the wish of clinician and
researcher is to find the most optimized
um
um
signature marker that can be used for
that has problematic
however bioinformatics
have a diverse diverse methodology to
answer this question
and there is no one that is better than
the other so the challenge for me was
how to choose the best methodology
and um
how to
to justify the why i have through this
methodology and not the other one
that was fun thank you a challenge that
uh
you haven't resolved
what prepared you for this position and
what do you think other students might
learn and master as they embark on their
own bioinformatics analysis
what was the first part of the question
sorry
what prepared you for the position
uh what prepared me um
about i during all the years every time
i have a new
question a new necessity on
bioinformatics i have to learn it so um
it's it's a learning process
um
and
what prepare me for this position is uh
during this uh my postdoc particularly i
had the opportunity to collaborate with
different persons that
present me in the end dr kusulas and
i think the fact that
i have this background in
molecular biology in
science research where i understand the
bench work i understand the
molecular process that
we are trying to understand it's um an
advantage
uh to help
um a researcher a student to um
for a project because i have this
balance between the molecular biology
and biologic context but also
know which kind of bioinformatic tools
are available to try to answer um
the different questions and furthermore
also when you have this balance it's um
maybe easier also to ask a science
biological question
um
i think sometimes
what i heard when biopharmaceuticians
were talking is
it's
difficult for them to have a clear
question of what they need to answer
with their tools
and so having this uh two
to expertise in a way help to have a
clear question to be ensured
very good thank you
so what do you think we have a lot of
students on our calls i know what do you
think students might want to learn and
master as they embark on their
bioinformatics analysis what what kind
of advice do you have
i think this would be interesting for
them to um at least maybe beginning to
master um
uh
some
free software as maybe r that is very
easy the ones that i i use on very basic
statistics and bioinformatics tools has
a
correlation analyses
that can be used for different
field
on research uh can be master
beginning to understand also a statistic
that can
[Music]
can be used in very diverse
field and
and are not very much specific for
molecular biology or immunology or this
or other thing so yeah it can be um
helpful to have a kind of basic
understanding of the
bioinformatic tools that
are available
very good thank you